well from booty to buccatini we're
talking pasta today's food news
[Applause]
finally okay i have been waiting for
this moment the good news network
reports that there's a new pasta shape
at the pasta party and she's a flying
off the shelves first and backstory dan
paschman james beard award winner and
food podcaster set out to create the
perfect pasta and he did a ton of
research tried every shape and even went
to a pasta lab by the way that's where i
want to be buried yeah all of a sudden i
want to be a scientist now no kidding
then he got with brooklyn pasta makers
fellini to invent the casca what the
hell
cascatelli cascatali caskatel by the way
everybody in italy right now is like
shut up
um cascatelli um so we're here to try it
it says that also it's got grooves and a
toothiness yeah it's important i think
for pasta sort of grab the sauce like
hey come on guys we're all gonna go in
together and look at that it totally
does it it's so good oh my god
i'm in
i love it
this is so delicious ross it's your
story yeah we could talk about noodles
all day long but congratulations by the
way i'm creating a new pasta it's about
time yeah well welcome to the family
koskitelli thank you so much
and
finally nature lovers looking for your
next big adventure look no further than
the llama
the washington post published a guide on
how to go hiking with a herd of llamas
because we've all been waiting for that
here's how you do it you don't ride the
llama no you hike alongside them and
it's called llama therapy because
because these guys are super peaceful
and they make the perfect packed animal
they're llamas all right and the point
is it's supposed to like chill you out a
little bit but when you look at these
pictures of these llamas i mean i never
thought i it's never occurred to me like
i'd love to go on a hike with a llama
until i looked at these pictures and now
all i can think about is going on a hike
with a llama
and you can like park them and camp out
and they just go with you for a while
what's what what's so funny parking a
llama
well i asked do you tether them like do
they just stay and you know watch out
for you at night like how i wanted to
know details you park them and then walk
away and go
anyway we're going to show on our
website some opportunities if you're
interested in getting with a llama and
going on a nature walk you can go for a
couple hours or a couple days
okay i don't i mean
are you guys gonna do this anyone gonna
nope
i see some people interested may i ask
why you raised your hands
well we're
we're actually taking our nine-year-old
to yellowstone in the next month or so
and she's really into uh alpacas and
llamas oh that's perfect it's perfect
for are you a plant
right
you can't be serious you're going to
yellowstone with your kid and she loves
llamas yes that is the truth
then ross we were looking for someone
that this story speaks to this is not
it's going to be a surprise to our
producers but i would love to hook you
up with a llama ride
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you